und dann hatte die afg noch parteitag in
dresden und entstanden ist dort ein
wahlprogramm das in seiner radikalität
sogar die parteiführung überrascht hat
eu-austritt steht da zum beispiel drin
war so nicht geplant steht da jetzt mann
ist für eine neue wehrpflicht aber und
jetzt kommt gegen die masken pflicht in
der korona krise wir erhalten im übrigen
auch den incidents wert für
manipulierbar
durch die ausweitung oder durch
einschränkungen der tests lässt sich der
incidents wert eben auch hoch oder
runter fahren ich frage mich warum sie
den das wort manipulation benutzen wenn
mehr getestet wird und man mehr fälle
findet dann ist das doch näher an der
wahrheit dran fragt dann nehmen sie
einfach korrelationen dann noch ja es
ist jetzt bitte fragen sie nicht was in
korrelation ist und so klingt alles
weiter wenn sie gut gelaunt ist das neue
wahlprogramm der afd
zu radikal oder einfach nur besonders
radikale kunst herzlich willkommen zu
am wochenende stellte die umstrittene
autorengruppe afd
in dresden ihr neues werk vor der titel
deutschland aber normal
offensichtlich eine hommage an den
großen deutschen humoristen tom gerhardt
wirft bereits fragen auf was meinen wir
damit genau was ist normal normal liebe
freunde ist es morgens aufzustehen ja
morgens aufstehen oder wie es
literarische vorgänger formulierten
deutschland erwache und damit sind wir
schon beim inhalt der geschichte es geht
um eine reise aber nicht an einen
anderen ort sondern in eine andere zeit
eine zeit mit grenzzäune wehrpflicht und
atomkraftwerken zurück zur d-mark raus
aus der eu
warum das alles weil die eu sterben wo
ist in deutschland leben will solch
martialische sprache findet man immer
wieder
ich zitiere die tugenden des soldaten
sind ehre treue kameradschaft und
tapferkeit soldatinnen bleiben unerwähnt
sie stehen wohl nur eine gulaschkanone
an anderer stelle wird das recht auf
waffen gefordert sogar auf englisch oder
man bereits feierabend
wer besonders gefährdet ist sollte sich
selber schützen können sie haben richtig
gehört bewaffnete bürger und den autoren
ist durchaus klar dass man sich hier auf
problematischen terrain bewegt es gibt
aber ein problem das wir immer nach zwei
verlorenen weltkriegen sehen müssen
2 verloren weltkriege und nur ein
problem ist so ein guter schnitt
ghostwriter dieses programm romans ist
übrigens ein gewisser bernd haake der
hier hemmungslos seinen hang zu
abstrusen ideen auslebt wir sind eine
gewachsene nation genau
im japan meer japan fragen eine
kafkaeske dystopie deutschland als
inselstaat bei weiter steigendem
meeresspiegel durchaus denkbar
als kritiker sollte man der
autorengruppe aber zu gute halten dass
es gar nicht so einfach ist im kollektiv
zu schreiben
bitte dieses ist durch hp hat ersetzen
sie brauchen wir das nicht lösen da ist
ein rechtschreibfehler drin schaden
schreibt man mit einer maus es ist ein
sehr großer schaden
bei all dem durcheinander bewahrten
einzelne zum glück doch den überblick
was passiert wenn man einen riesigen
text abstimmt der gar nicht an der saar
versteht keiner hat was gelesen
wir haben nicht gewusst für über die
abgestimmt haben und spätestens wenn ein
storch die stimme der vernunft ist kann
man sich sicher sein
normal ist das nicht guten abend
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll auslasten abo
da